there's heinz field with the pittsburgh
steelers play
now fired miami dolphins head coach
brian flores is back in the nfl less
than three weeks after suing the league
in three teams four leads racial
discrimination in their higher hiring
practices the pittsburgh steelers hired
flores as their senior defensive
assistant and linebackers coach flores
led the dolphins to back-to-back winning
seasons for the first time in nearly two
decades but he was let go in january his
hiring does not affect the lawsuit but
it does give floris a chance to make a
difference with a new team
you still want to coach in this league i
absolutely want to coach in this league
less than three weeks ago brian flores
was not sure he'd get that chance again
now despite a lawsuit alleging racial
discrimination by the nfl and three
teams allegations they all deny he's a
defensive assistant for the pittsburgh
steelers led by super bowl champion mike
tomlin the second longest tenured coach
in the nfl and one of five minority or
biracial head coaches in a league where
about 70 percent of the players are
black in a statement tomlin said brian's
resume speaks for itself and i look
forward to him adding his expertise to
help our team this off season nine teams
had head coaching vacancies flores had
interviewed for three of them only one
team the houston texans hired a black
man levy smith as their head coach we
didn't have to file a lawsuit for for
the world to know that there's a problem
from a from a hiring standpoint in
regards to minority coaches in the
national football league the numbers
speak for themselves right we filed a
lawsuit
so that we could create some change in
his lawsuit florida alleged he was
interviewed for coaching vacancies
solely to satisfy the nfl's so-called
rooney rule which requires teams to
interview multiple minority candidates
when filling high-level jobs like head
coach or general manager the nfl has
insisted flores lawsuit is without merit
but is conducting a review of its hiring
policies including the rooney rule named
after dan rooney whose family founded
and owns the steelers flores admitted
his suit could cost him his career and
his calling i understand the risk
and yes it was a difficult decision and
i went back and forth
and like i said i
i love coaching i do but this is bigger
than
than that now on a pittsburgh team in
need of a defensive overhaul flores has
an opportunity to thrive says the
undefeated's bill rhoden it was a
perfect move uh number one the steals
were awful defensively you know so you
know red black or green suit or no suit
they needed
as much defense as they can get and if
there's any franchise
that should have come to the rescue it
was pittsburgh because remember
pittsburgh and the rooney family came up
with the rooney rule so it was perfect
that pittsburgh would be part of the
underground railroad that would come in
and rescue and say you know not on our
watch i mean this guy is a quality head
coach everybody knows it
and that's bill keeping it real rodent
that's right
florence's attorneys they say the
lawsuit will continue regardless of his
employment status the nfl has hired
former u.s attorney general loretta
lynch to lead its defense that's an
interesting choice too bill rhoden
certainly did put it in perspective but
it is nice to see brian flores back in
the league isn't it it is it still keeps
him in the game it keeps him in the game
and it also keeps them in the loop what
happens is when these coaches are fired
they're immediately hired for a couple
of reasons let's just keep it real um
their resume like flores or they know
somebody on another staff that basically
brings them in cuts them a check and
they stay inside that coaching circle so
they can always have a job available